a veteran of uk us
relations joe biden knew how to make him
and him and him feel
special turning on the charm whatever
their political stripe
but testing times ahead for boris
johnson in leicester today
facing the prospect of another
regeneration of the special relationship
as brexit means britain is trying to
work out its new place in the world
the prime minister united kingdom is
always going to work very very closely
with
whoever is the the prime minister of the
president of the united states and
uh that's going to be the case uh
whatever the outcome and i have every
confidence that the in the the checks
and balances of the american
constitution
whitehall on the cusp of a new us
president everybody holding their breath
boris johnson looks set to lose a
personal ally in the white house
but this could be the moment to reset
the special relationship based on values
rather than personalities
the united kingdom believes in the
united nations the paris climate changer
called the rule of law the world health
organization
and we're probably about to get somebody
in the white house who says they
do too but there'll be a big early
challenge for boris johnson
he needs to show he's a good global
citizen but could brexit
mess that up we may well have a new u.s
president who sees brexit
more through the eyes of ireland
something britain is acutely aware of
biden we know is proud of his irish
roots is absolutely
opposed to anything that could
jeopardize the good friday
peace process i suspect the government
will be more inclined to compromise
on some of these difficult issues where
they're currently reluctant to do so
knowing just how much time joe biden has
spent researching his irish roots
irish officials told sky news that if
relationships break down over brexit
they hope he could pay a symbolic visit
to the irish border
through many many presidential elections
there has been an irish
imprint an irish influence and
this election is no different the last
thing we need now is an ordeal brexit
that would
just add significantly to that type of
negative shock which people could do
without now
out of westminster political leaders
showing more excitement at the potential
for
change going on stateside i hope
the outcome of the election it does see
at the united states of america
re-take that important position of
leadership on these big issues we
desperately need the united states
that shows a global leadership on the
climate emergency
in relation to dealing with the virus on
matters of inequality
of trade and of stability
working together on trade and climate
change is what boris johnson wants
too even if he can't quite say so today
the challenge will be forging a
relationship with a man
he's hitherto not even met sam coates
sky news
leicester